if you have to blink do it now Kubo in
the two strings this is the latest
offering from Leica Animation I love
their stuff I haven't reviewed it on the
channel before because I haven't been
doing this long enough to have done the
ones that I've seen and patches still
haven't gotten around the boxtrolls but
I really like their stuff I like their
visual style I like the kinds of stories
they tend to tack - I love their
ambition and Kubo very much in their
wheelhouse first of all I shouldn't even
have to say this it is gorgeous it looks
amazing it looks stunning I I mean I'm a
sucker for stop-motion animation anyway
but it's just inventive it's gorgeous
it doesn't try and hide the fact that
this stuff is handmade you can see the
seams and in a way that kind of makes it
a little bit more beautiful a little bit
more endearing so it's just beautiful to
look at story-wise it's pretty basic and
it's really very fundamental it's a very
standard young boy with a destiny to
fulfill on a quest kind of thing but
it's borrowing all of its elements from
Eastern mythology as opposed to Western
mythology so what that means is instead
of dragons and castles and wizards we
instead get yo sisters with masks who
summon smoke beasts and moon kings and
origami brought to life by a kid playing
a stringed instrument and it's awesome
and I do I do wanna say this was a
really good movie and looked great I had
a lot of fun it had some really good
emotional moments throughout but there
was something about it
coming out of the theater that it was
like I feel like I should have liked
that a little bit more that I did and it
took me a little while to figure out
what it was
there's just something slightly off
about the balance in terms of its appeal
towards older and younger audience and
it does have appeal to both and again
this is a good movie don't let what I'm
about to say make you think otherwise
and if you like anything like it has
we've done before absolutely see this
but here's the thing I was watching it
and there are certain aspects of the
plot and the story I don't want to call
them twists but there's certain roads
that the narrative goes down that are
kind of predictable and honestly that's
the sort of thing that I am liable to
give a pass on for a movie aimed at kids
but the thing is it's a little too
slowly paces a little too contemplative
to get away with that in my mind and by
that I mean I actually brought my
daughter to this movie with me and she
did enjoy it she didn't check out
completely but I could see her interest
wavering so it spaced a little too
slowly for young kids yet is trying to
get away with the sorts of narrative
shortcuts and standard you know turns of
the story that really you can only get
away with if you're appealing to young
kids who haven't seen a lot and already
know you know that these are tropes so
it doesn't quite nail the sweet spot
that ParaNorman nail now ParaNorman is
also movies that you know I actually am
NOT gonna try and show my daughter for a
while because she's not all done because
that movie is older it is more
contemplative but it also has things
that go on with the story particularly
at the end of that movie that is like it
really earns the fact that it has that
slower pacing this Kubo and the two
strains like I said there's a couple of
narrative shortcuts that they take that
I'm calling if you're gonna try and do
that you need to pick up the pace of the
thing overall but again this was a
really good movie it was a really fun
movie it was a gorgeous movie the action
scenes are really good it had good heart
it's just it's not it doesn't quite nail
the balance that I think like oh was
going for odds are still gonna show up
in my top 10 at the end of the year but
I had my Nick picks and it seems like
with other reviews I'm seeing and
reading I'm the only one who feels this
way so I'm gonna throw it out there see
if I get eaten alive or not but what
were your thoughts on this if you see it
if you haven't seen it what is your
favorite like an animation film if you
haven't guessed already
mine's ParaNorman but what is it for you
whatever it is drop something down on
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
it a listen to the council of geeks
podcast home of 90's comics retrial that
is available on itunes and stitcher
and until next time I will be back as
soon as I can get my next fix